yes I shaved my shadow and a stupid
month called No Shave November why
because I don't want to look like the
guy from Superman 2 by the end it's that
simple Tower Heist are so tower high
stars Ben Stiller and he's the manager
of this really upper-class hotel and in
the very top penthouse lives Alan Alda
who's this really rich rich rich guy
like one of those guys you hate he's so
rich and at first Alan Alda was really
cool you know he's like oh yeah he's
just really a nice old rich guy I'm like
yeah he's cold [ __ ] but he was so
nice I was like there's no way this
guy's gonna be the bad guy then it turns
out Alan Alda has taken and lost the
money of everyone who invested with him
which is Ben Stiller Matthew Broderick
and the rest of the crew and now he's an
[ __ ]
and so Ben Stiller and his crew are like
alright we're gonna break into his
penthouse and we're gonna take our money
back only thing is they're like dude we
don't know how to break into anything so
Ben Stiller looks like it's alright I
know someone who does and so in walks
Eddie Murphy and I'm pretty sure that
most of the reviews you hear are gonna
say I thought Eddie Murphy was gonna be
really annoying in this movie it turns
out he's one of the best parts and it's
really true Eddie Murphy is like one of
the best parts in this movement he
wasn't in it a lot I mean he was in it
but he didn't overshadow anything weird
thing is though in thinking back about
the movie I don't know why he's actually
in it I mean it kind of seems like they
could have pulled this job off by
themselves they didn't need any Murphy
it's almost like Brett Ratner was like
oh I'm gonna add Eddie Murphy because I
want to cuz I just love 48 hours and
when the guy who killed the x-men
franchise before it was brought back and
then killed again before it was brought
back for real says he wants Eddie Murphy
in a movie you give it to him no did I
like this movie I did I enjoyed it there
were just things about the movie that I
was like that seems kind of choppy or
the way they did that I was like that
wouldn't work I'm one of those people I
hate being one of those douchebags that
looks at a movie and like that wouldn't
work I don't call [ __ ] on light
sabers in Star Wars that's perfectly
fine with me but the moment you give a
guard a playboy and it locks him up and
he's like paying attention to this
playboy for about six hours during a
heist never looking at the monitors once
because that's how it's supposed to
happen that's when I call [ __ ]
unless he was reading the articles in
which case I thought everyone did a
really good job in this movie I liked
the premise of the movie I liked the
fact that these blue color people are
going after the rich douchebag that lost
all their money if only we could do that
in real life that would be awesome so
where the scenes choppy some of the time
was it realistic note was it fun yeah I
mean if you're really grounded in
reality and you want a realistic heist
movie or at least a movie that's as good
as ocean
11 or the Italian job you might want to
catch this movie in the matinee well
terror heist be relevant in a couple
weeks and probably not I'll probably
forget I even saw it but as for right
now for a movie this weekend that's not
Harold and Kumar which is hilarious by
the way you can check out my review just
saying Tower Heist is not a bad choice
so for like the tenth time in the past
month I will say that this movie is a
good time no alcohol required I almost
wanted to not like it so much for the
sake of variety so I can give it a
different rating system but I can't
knock a movie because I want to give it
another rating system I can't do that
and Tower Heist was fun so I already
asked you what your favorite heist movie
was so I can't ask you that but what's
your favorite Brett Ratner movie all two
of them that might be your favorite
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]